ja Patricia hier ist er viele Buchstaben
viel Papier und das ist sozusagen die
Kurzfassung des Koalitionsvertrages und
das ist ihr erster Blick da rein also
das soll die nächsten vier Jahre
bestimmen diese Worte die hier auf
diesem Papier verewigt wurde an den
stundenlang geschraubt wurde zuletzt bis
tief in die Nacht hinein Olaf Scholze
erst viertel nach 2 Uhr nach Hause
gegangen in der vergangenen Nacht und
das ein ganz wichtiger Satz an dem
werden wir die Ampel messen wir machen
Politik die das Leben der Menschen ganz
konkret besser macht das also ein
wesentliches Ziel der ampelregierung für
die nächsten vier Jahre und jetzt wollen
wir natürlich wissen das ist ja ein
gutes Ziel aber wie will man das denn
machen und das ist dann auf den
folgenden Seiten auch aufgeführt und
etwas konkreter gefasst zum Beispiel
soll es zu Modernisierung des
Sozialstaates ein neues Bürgergeld geben
das Punkt 1 und dann ganz entscheidend
der Mindestlohn das war ja die zentrale
wahlkampfforderung das
Wahlkampfversprechen von Olaf Scholz im
SPD-Wahlkampf der Mindestlohn von 12
Euro der kommt und da sagt die Ampel
jetzt in ihrem Papier ganz konkret das
ist eine Gehaltserhöhung für 10
Millionen Menschen das also ganz wichtig
und zentral in diesem Ampel
Koalitionsvertrag dann ganz wichtig das
was drunter steht für alle jungen
Menschen für alle Jugendlichen in
Deutschland es kommt das Wahlrecht ab 16
bundesweit das will die Ampel also dann
da braucht sie Zustimmung auch in den
Ländern im Bundesrat aber das will die
Ampel tatsächlich durchboxen in den
nächsten vier Jahren die Ampel
verspricht auch eine Ausbildungsplatz
Garantie für alle jungen Menschen eine
Reform des Bafögs also das ganz gezielt
die Ansprache von FDP und Grüne die ja
so viele junge Wähler hatten bei dieser
Bundestagswahl an alle Jugendlichen und
jungen Deutschen wir gehen weiter und da
sehen wir schon bezahlbar wohnen ist
hier die Überschrift das ist also ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt für die Ampel und
das fasst sie auch relativ konkret wie
will man das denn schaffen also nicht
nur das höhere Ziel sondern zuletzt sind
zwar ganz oft solche Versprechen
versprechen geblieben konnten dann nicht
umgesetzt werden und doch nennt sich die
Ampel eine ganz konkrete Zahl 400.000
neue Wohnungen will man bauen und zwar
in jedem Jahr jährlich das ist das Ziel
hier werden wir die Ampel dran messen
dürfen nach vier Jahren Regierung
darunter sollen 100.000 also von diesen
400.000 neuen Wohnungen 100.000 auch
öffentlich gefördert sein die
mietpreisbremse gleich darunter die soll
verlängert werden also bezahlbares
Wohnen ein ganz wichtiger Punkt und hier
unten geht es dann um den Punkt
Inflation der die hohen Energiepreise
ganz großes Thema hier bei Bild ganz
großes Thema für Sie in Ihrem Alltag in
den vergangenen Wochen und Monaten da
sagt die Ampel noch einmal nach da haben
wir ja schon den ersten Beschluss
gefasst nämlich
in den Heizkostenzuschuss für Einkommen
schwache Familien das ganz wichtige
lebensnahe Themen die man hier
vorangestellt hat besonders geheilt hat
in diesem Koalitionsvertrag Klimaschutz
und Industrie klar wichtiger Punkt nicht
nur aber vor allen Dingen natürlich für
die Grünen in diesem Koalitionsvertrag
und da setzt man auf massiven Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energie also massiv ist das
entscheidende Wort will man Netze
Windräder die Infrastruktur ausbauen und
man will dafür gleichzeitig sorgen oder
daran werden wir die Ampel messen dass
Energie bezahlbar bleibt bei uns im Land
und ganz wichtig der letzte Satz hier
unten dieser unser Anspruch ist dass die
klimafreundliche Lösung immer die
einfachere ist also Klimaschutz soll
keine Last sein in den nächsten vier
Jahren Rente das wichtigste
Wahlkampfthema für die meisten deutschen
und auch deswegen ein zentraler Punkt
hier im Koalitionsvertrag Rente ganz
klar sagt die Ampel Renten werden nicht
gekürzt das Rentenniveau bleibt und auch
das Renteneintrittsalter wird nicht
erhöht dass das Versprechen der
ampelregierung und dann schauen wir noch
einmal ganz wichtig auf das Thema
Familie und Kinder da wird die Ampel so
wie es auch schon in dem ersten Papier
dem sondierungspapier der Ampel stand
eine Kindergrundsicherung einführen
zentraler Punkt im Koalitionsvertrag und
dann dieses Versprechen und auch das
müssen sich ganz genau anschauen es wird
ein Jahrzehnt der bildungsschancen
gestartet die Ampel startet ein
Jahrzehnt der Bildungschancen mit dem
ganz konkreten versprechen wir lassen es
nicht mehr zu dass unsere Kita Kinder in
marode Schulen und Kitas gehen wir
lassen das nicht mehr zu ein Satz an dem
sich die Ampel wird messen lassen in den
nächsten vier Jahren letztes versprechen
hier in dieser Kurzfassung des
Koalitionsvertrags betrifft den Bereich
Gesundheit und Pflege da ist unter
anderem die Rede von einer Einrichtung
eines corona-krisen möglicherweise das
etwas für Karl Lauterbach ein
corona-krisenstab wird eingerichtet um
die aktuelle corona-krise bestmöglich zu
wuppen und dann sollen ganz konkret
Altenpflegerinnen und Altenpfleger
besser belohnt besser entlohnt werden
hier stets wichtige Arbeit soll
angemessen bezahlt werden deshalb
verbessern wir die Löhne in der
Altenpflege also ganz konkret auch das
ein Versprechen an alle Altenpfleger und
Pflegerinnen in Deutschland genügend
Stoff zu Diskussionen mit dir Patrizia
und Paul rotzheimer
ja vielen herzlichen Dank Kai das also
die ersten Seiten des Koalitionsvertrag
um 15 Uhr gibt es eine Pressekonferenz
mit weiteren Details bei mir Paul
ronsheimer unser Bild Vize Paul das ist
auch in den vergangenen Tagen beobachtet
jetzt sehen wir das zum ersten Mal jetzt
nach dem sondierungspapier das ja schon
recht konkret war sehen wir schwarz auf
weiß wohnen Mindestlohn Bildung das sind
die großen Themen der Ampel überrascht
sich da irgendetwas was mich überrascht
ist wie klar sich die FDP insgesamt
durchgesetzt hat nicht nur thematisch
sondern auch angesichts der Ministerien
wenn wir uns anschauen dass die FDP
Finanzen bekommen hat Verkehr Justiz
Bildung alle wichtigen
zukunftsministerien oder zumindest vier
wichtige zukunftsministerium besetzt
dann auch noch Finanzen wo Christian
Lindner immer wird sagen können nein
dafür ist nicht genug Geld da also er
sitzt auf der Kohle der künftigen
Koalition da muss man sagen Respekt FDP
was die alles durchgesetzt haben
gleichzeitig die Grünen sich aber auch
gut positioniert viele waren jetzt heute
überrascht dass Anna-Lena baerbock ist
geschafft hat ihr Ziel ihr zweites Ziel
nach Kanzlerin zu werden dann zu
verwirklichen und sie wird
Außenministerin ich war nicht überrascht
dass einer der bärburg Außenministerin
geworden ist oder wird das ist etwas was
eigentlich in den Verhandlungen von
Anfang an sie klargemacht hat ich will
ins Ausland das war eigentlich auch
schon in der in dem Wahlkampf ihr Ziel
das hat man gemerkt am Ende sie wollte
sich da nur noch rein retten und nicht
zu sehr beschädigt werden als das die
Koalition noch gefährdet werden könnte
als Junior Partnerin ich glaube dass die
Grünen die größten Probleme bekommen
werden in mit ihrer Basis wir dürfen ja
eins nicht vergessen wir sehen eine
reale linke Regierung so würde ich es
mal nennen mit eigentlich guten Köpfen
keine verrückten die man jetzt auf den
ersten Blick sieht in den Ministerien
ministerlisten aber wenn wir uns
anschauen wie links die Fraktionen sind
die Grünen die SPD wer da alles im
Bundestag sitzt dann glaube ich werden
die Grünen bei ihrem Parteitag zu hören
bekommen dass sie nicht genügend
umgesetzt haben was das Thema Klima
angeht jetzt haben wir gerade die ersten
Inhalte aus dem Koalitionsvertrag
gesehen Paul meint erster Eindruck war
so ein bisschen es ist schon ein relativ
vielen Punkten ziemlich konkret
vielleicht konkreter als vergangene
Koalitionsverträge in denen sie ja ganz
lange viele Seiten immer wieder finden
wo man ganz schnell durchblättern kann
aber hier gibt es konkrete Versprechen
ist das gefährlich für die Ampel denn
ich habe ja immer wieder gesagt daran
wird sie sich messen lassen müssen das
ist gefährlich und gleichzeitig eine
Chance ich glaube wenn man sagen kann
Häkchen dran wir haben tatsächlich diese
Zahl erreicht dann ist es für die Bürger
viel klarer zu sehen hatte diese
Regierung Erfolg und wenn es ein
realistisches Ziel ist und davon gehe
ich aus dass man sich dort realistische
Ziele gesetzt hat 400.000 Wohnungen
klingt viel aber eins darf man nicht
vergessen das war das Thema insbesondere
der SPD im Wahlkampf denn wir sehen die
mietensteigerung für viele Menschen
großes Problem und das zum Thema machen
mit einer klaren Zahl finde ich klug
keine klaren Zahlen gibt es bei den aus
mehr Ausgaben für Bildung die
angekündigt werden und auch bei den
Mehrausgaben in der Altenpflege die
angekündigt werden da hat man sich also
nicht ganz so weit aus dem Fenster
gewagt wie jetzt beim Thema wohnen wir
holen jetzt in unser Gespräch Peter dazu
unser Chefreporter der ja bis in die
frühen Morgenstunden und auch gleich
wieder heute morgen für uns da ist mit
weiteren Einschätzungen jetzt in dieser
absolut heißen Phase es ist nicht mehr
lange hin knapp zwei Stunden noch dann
wissen wir alle Details aus diesem
Koalitionsvertrag Peter kannst du schon
einschätzen was uns da sonst noch
erwartet
ja gute Laune also man wird jetzt sagen
wir haben uns zusammengefunden und das
waren harte Verhandlung das muss man
sagen damit man damit auch vor die
Partei treten kann und da muss man
dieses Knie blutige Nase blaues Auge
vorzeigen können und sagen können aber
guck mal was wir alles gewonnen haben
und schaut euch mal die anderen an wie
schlimm die aussehen also so die
klassische Kneipenschlägerei das ist die
Geschichte die man hinterher erzählt ich
hasse blaues Auge aber die anderen haben
zwei das wird kommen und dann wird es
richtig groß dann wird die
Konfettikanone angeschmissen und die
gute Laune kommt aus einem Boxen raus
das macht man das ist auch schon
intoniert bei Tweets von Lars Klingbeil
das hat ja alles angefangen mit einem
Tweet der Grünen und der FDP als man die
die Nation damit überrascht hat dass man
doch schon relativ schnell an einem
Abend mal so eine Art vor Sondierung
zwischen grün und gelb angefangen hat
und jetzt gibt's einen selfie von den
generellen und zwar von lasking bei der
SPD Generalsekretär veröffentlicht mit
Herrn Wissing von der FDP und dem Herrn
Kellner von den Grünen also am Anfang
war ein Zweier selfie am Ende ist ein
Dreier selfie ein Koalitionsvertrag und
ein Kabinett das wird man heute
gebührenstaats tragen vortragen weil man
ist ja jetzt quasi nur noch diesen
halben piss Fortschritt von der
Regierung entfernt man hat die
Koalitionsvertrag man muss jetzt noch
durch die Partei Gremien durch
staatstragend und mit Stolz wird man das
heute alles vortragen also das wird
jetzt die Tonlage ab spätestens 15 Uhr
ist ja klar dass man sich jetzt nicht
mehr gegenseitig da wegrätscht man will
ja zusammen regieren aber trotzdem du
hast ja jetzt über Wochen das ganze
Theater da verfolgt dass die ganze
Regierungsbildung Peter wie viel ja
vielleicht Heuchelei oder im besten Fall
guter Wille ist im Spiel denn weiterhin
ist es ja Hofreiter muss mit Lindner
funktionieren zum Beispiel esken muss
mit
Göring-Eckardt und Lindner und so weiter
funktionieren also das sind ja nicht
bisher die ganz großen Freundschaften
gewesen wird das funktionieren
ja was ist auch es ist ja auch keine
freundesreise also hier gehen ja jetzt
nicht drei Parteien die sich richtig
knorke finden mal eben mal so zum so zum
Campingurlaub oder zum Mangel Ausflug
das ist harte Arbeit da muss man sich
nicht immer gut verstehen sondern man
muss ein gemeinsames Ziel haben man muss
sich eigentlich darüber sein dass man
dem anderen auch mal etwas gönnen können
muss und dass das dann dass das mit dazu
gehört neu war für mich tatsächlich die
Art und Weise wie verhandelt worden ist
wir Journalisten schwierig die haben mir
quasi wie wie Schwangere aus da haben
die haben die hier verhandelt es gab
nichts nach außen hat Bilder vermieden
Annalena Berber hatte zum Anfang mal
gesagt die Journalisten werden nicht
einmal erfahren was auf dem Brötchen ist
Käse oder Wurst bisschen was haben wir
denn am Ende doch erfahren aber so hat
man verhandelt und man hat vor einem
vertrauensvoll miteinander verhandelt
und das war das Signal dass man
auszusenden wollte dass hier das ist
hier um Vertrauen geht dass man weiß
dass es heikel ist das ein Dreier
Bündnis mit dieser politischen Spreizung
wirklich heikel ist und dass man
deswegen auch schon anders miteinander
umgehen muss von Anfang an wenn diese
Tonlage hält diese respektvolle Tonlage
nicht wie in groko wo es ja wirklich
teilweise schrill herging dann kann das
tatsächlich der Anfang eines neuen
politischen Tons in Deutschland sein ich
wachse noch zu bezweifeln weil jedem
Anfang wohnt einen Zauber inne aber mit
gehöriger Wegstrecke wird es dann auch
manchmal disharmonischer aber die Art
und Weise wie verhandelt worden ist die
Tonlage die angeschlagen worden ist das
ist schon etwas anderes das ist der
Versuch etwas neues auf dem Weg zu
stellen und ihr habt es gerade
angesprochen mit dem Passagen aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag da stehen ganz ganz
konkrete Sachen drin schon in der
Kurzfassung man darf also noch mal
gespannt sein auch auf die längere
Version da steht ja dann noch mehr drin
das ist dann auch noch mal ausgetauscht
und das ist schon wirklich ungewöhnlich
und das zeigt aber auch dass man sich
messen lassen will und dass man
ernsthaft wirklich große Projekte
angehen will die müssen einmal politisch
vielleicht nicht gefallen das mag auch
nicht die Gesellschaft mit eines jeden
deutschen irgendwie entsprechen aber
zumindest haben sie Ambitionen die
stellen sie deutlich raus die werden
bezahlen und untermauert und sie machen
sich selbst messbar und das ist schon
etwas da haben sie die Latte ein
bisschen höher gelegt als sie bisher lag
in diesem Land
das ist angesprochen Peter man kann
schwer sagen was ich hinter den Kulissen
abspielt darauf wurde dieses mal ganz
genau geachtet das würde ich nichts nach
draußen trinkt es ist auch weniger als
zwei Stunden hast du irgendwelche
Informationen darüber wie alle
Beteiligten diese zwei Stunden jetzt
verbringen sitzt man da schon hinter den
Kulissen stößt an und sagt Mensch auf
die Ampel endlich ist die Grünen
geschaltet es geht los und er wird da
jetzt noch so ein bisschen an
irgendetwas rumgeschraubt
also Shampoos gibt es wahrscheinlich
erst heute und den auch nur hinter den
Kulissen öffentlich angestoßen wird erst
wenn man durch die Parteien durch ist
das heißt für die SPD und für die Grünen
das ist jetzt an die an die Basis geht
das dauert jetzt noch ein paar Tage bis
man damit durch ist und damit dann auch
der Traum von Olaf Scholz in Erfüllung
gehen kann dass er der erste
nikolauskanzler Deutschlands wird also
in der Nikolaus Woche will er Kanzler
werden der Mann der gerne immer als
stumpf dargestellt wird also Schlumpf
Nikolaus der neue Kanzler bis dahin ist
es noch eine Weile aber jetzt zur Zeit
sind alle drei Parteien mit dem was sie
hier errungen haben oder was sie sich
gegenseitig abgeholt haben und für sich
erreicht haben in ihren Partei Gremien
Partei Gremien heißt und Parteivorstand
und im Präsidium bei der FDP ist das
eine digitale Tagung bei der bei der CDU
auch und ich nehme alles bei den Grünen
ähnliches also jetzt informiert man
bevor die Nation ist erfährt bevor man
vor die Presse geht werden die
Parteispitzen informiert die kriegen
jetzt den Koalitionsvertrag und die
erfahren jetzt auch wer bei Ihnen wohl
Minister wird
danke an Bild Chefin auf jeden Fall in
Berlin all den Stunden der Verhandlungen
während der Koalitionsvertrag dahinter
den Kulissen jetzt ganz oft gedruckt und
immer wieder gedruckt wird damit alle
ihn in Deutschland tatsächlich auch
lesen können sofern nicht digitalisiert
danke Peter und wir wollen reinholen in
die Runde Wolfgang Bosbach CDU Urgestein
mit der ersten Reaktion werden Paul noch
mal sein Handy checkt Wolfgang Bosbach
herzlich willkommen bei Bild live was
überwiegt heute bei ihnen gibt es bei
Ihnen an diesem Tag an dem hier im
politischen Berlin so das Gefühl
verbreitet werden soll von geschafft
jetzt packen wir es an vermittelt sich
ihnen ein bisschen diese
Aufbruchstimmung oder es ist einfach der
Schmerz zu tief sitzen dass die Union
nicht dabei ist
schöne Grüße aus Hamburg es ist jetzt
nicht anders als es 1998 war als
Schröder Fischer an die Macht gekommen
sind und man wird sich gegenseitig loben
man wird sich auf die Schulter klopfen
natürlich wird auch ein Glas Sekt
getrunken an wird ein rhetorisches
Feuerwerk abgebrannt der Tenor wird sein
jetzt wird alles neuer schöner besser
größer und am nächsten Tag beginnt dann
der Alltag und dann wird sich die
Ampelkoalition an dem messen lassen was
sie verspricht was sie versprochen hat
und bin mit der Redaktion Bild
überrascht wie viel Konkretes ist also
die Latte liegt wirklich hoch und dann
bin ich gespannt ob alles das eins zu
eins abgearbeitet wird was in dem
Koalitionsvertrag anzusicherung gemacht
wurde und ich weiß papier ist geduldig
der politische Alltag ist wesentlich
anstrengender nehmen sie nur ein
einziges Beispiel 400.000 neue Wohnungen
das kannst du schreiben du brauchst aber
auch Fläche du brauchst Investoren du
brauchst Baurecht dann bin ich mal
gespannt wie die Koalition das alles
hinbekommen will in kurzer Zeit die
Ziele sind also hochgesteckt und
gleichzeitig hat dieser Tag ja auch
schon Erkenntnis darüber gebracht welche
Posten an wen vergeben werden zumindest
ein paar sind schon bekannt gab es da
für sie Überraschungen
nein im Großen und Ganzen war damit zu
rechnen jedenfalls mit der
Ressortverteilung und das war doch von
Anfang an klar die FDP kann überhaupt
nicht auf das Finanzministerium
verzichten soweit erinnere ich hat
Christian Lindner noch nie regiert jetzt
ist er zum ersten Mal in
Regierungsverantwortung hat ein ganz
ganz bedeutendes Ministerium bekommen
und jetzt kann und jetzt muss er
beweisen dass er nicht nur ein
glänzender Rhetoriker sondern auch ein
guter Finanzminister ist er wird aber
auch beim Amtsantritt merken alleine
dadurch dass jetzt eher statt Olaf
Scholz Finanzminister geworden ist aber
keine Euro mehr in der Kasse da sind ja
ein paar schillernde Namen schon dabei
also habe ergeben Wirtschaftsminister
Christian Lindner Finanzminister
Anna-Lena baerbock künftig
Außenministerin gibt es irgendjemanden
auf den sie sich ein diese Ministeramt
besonders freuen oder gibt es jemanden
über den sich freuen dass das nicht
geworden ist
also gespannt bin ich auf die
Performance von Annalena baerbock ich
mag sich jetzt etwas merkwürdig anhören
für einen CDU-Politiker dessen Parteien
die Opposition geschickt wurde aber als
Bürger dieses Landes wünsche ich mir
eine gute Bundesregierung ich kann mir
gar nicht wünschen als Staatsbürger dass
wir eine schlechter Regierung haben oder
Minister die im Amt Versagen aber ich
kann mir auch vorstellen so viel Kritik
Heiko Maas in den letzten Jahren
erfahren hat und nicht alle Kritik war
grundlos vielleicht werden demnächst
einige sagen es war doch kein guter
Tausch Anna Lena baerburg Stadt Heiko
Maas aber zunächst drücke ich allen
Beteiligten die Daumen und hoffe dass
sie in ihrem Amt realisieren Herr muss
mal wo sehen Sie das größte
krachpotential in dieser neuen Regierung
wie wird das Aussehen werden sich da
Christian Lindner und Anton Hofreiter ja
Balken was glauben Sie wie geht das aus
also zunächst glaube ich nicht dass die
grüne Basis des scheitern lassen wird
die haben so ein Spaß am regieren dass
sie jetzt wieder regieren können 2005
ist ja Rot-Grün gescheitert jetzt hat
man wieder die Möglichkeit nach 16
Jahren selbstverständlich wird die Basis
das Projekt nicht aufhalten da wird es
ein bisschen Kritik geben und am Ende
wird es eine große Mehrheit geben
spannend ist wenn die Ampelkoalition auf
die Realität trifft wenn wir zu dem
Kleingedruckten kommen wenn das was
jetzt in Prosa niedergeschrieben wird in
Gesetzessprache umgesetzt werden soll
ein kleines Beispiel nur max sich flap
sich anhören ist aber nicht falsch
Mehrheit hin Mehrheit her gegen die
Physik wirst du nicht gewinnen können
wir schalten nächstes Jahr die letzten
Kernkraftwerke ab die letzten dreien die
da noch am Netz sein werden haben im
vergangenen Jahr so viel Strom
produziert wie die Hälfte aller
Windräder in Deutschland ihr glaubt in
irgendeiner ernsthaft dass wir bis Ende
nächsten Jahres 50% mehr windr am Abend
als wir sie jetzt schon haben ich glaube
daran nicht natürlich hatten wir dem
Ziel fest aus Bar erneuerbare Energien
aber es muss doch alles realistisch sein
und wenn wir aus der Kohle Verstromung
aussteigen ist denn sichergestellt dass
wir bei dunkelflaute weder Kohlestrom
noch Atomstrom aus dem Ausland
importieren müssen dass wir eine
grundlastfähigkeit alleine mit
erneuerbaren Energien haben es wäre doch
ein Witz des Jahrhunderts wenn wir aus
Kohle und Atomstrom aussteigen und
anschließend aus Kohle Mailand und
Atomkraftwerken Strom importieren müssen
wo die Kraftwerke weniger leistungsfähig
eine Regierung oder Wirkungskraft haben
und die Atome meiner nicht so sicher
sind wie bei uns Herr Butzbach ein Wort
noch zu ihrer Partei zu denjenigen die
da jetzt die Autoschlüssel abgeben
müssen die keine Sicherheit mehr haben
die ausziehen müssen aus den Ministerien
wie sehr schmerzt das wenn man sieht
dass man nicht mehr dabei ist
also mit einem habe ich schon sprechen
können mit Gersten Müller
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit der war
enorm entspannt und freut sich jetzt auf
ein neues Leben anderer werden es anders
sehen ich habe gestern noch mit dem
Staatssekretär gesprochen
also dann zum Rednerpult gegen hat er
gesagt Batman Walking habe ich gesagt
wobei ihr Kopf hoch Leben geht weiter
also es ist immer wichtig dass die
Politik ein wichtiger Teil des Lebens
ist die öffentliche Verantwortung die
wir haben die ist wichtig aber wir
selber sind es doch nicht es gibt schon
gute Gründe warum ich mich nicht hundert
Prozent nie von der Politik habe
abhängig machen lassen ich habe das
immer sehr sehr ernst genommen meine
Aufgaben aber ich wollte nie nur
Politiker sein und zur Demokratie gehört
auch der Wechsel damit muss man rechnen
wir haben alle nur Verträge für vier
Jahre und das kann sich immer wieder
ändern jetzt gibt es bestimmt einige die
steigen jetzt nächste Woche noch hinten
rechts ein und sehen dass der Wagen
nicht losfährt aber da kann ich nicht
helfen und man darf jetzt auch nicht in
Trauer versehen das hat man da Leben
geht das hat man dann relativ schnell
kapiert glaube ich allerdings das nichts
fährt noch eine letzte Frage was ist der
Tipp was macht Angela Merkel in Zukunft
ich weiß wir können alle nicht in die
Glaskugel gucken sie wird es Ihnen
wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht verraten
haben aber was ist ihr Tipp
ich glaube das ist zwei Phasen geben
wird in der ersten Phase wo eine große
Belastung abfällt wo sie mal die Füße
hochlegt und die Dinge pflegt zu denen
sie bis jetzt keine Zeit hatte sie ist
ja eine Liebhaberin zum Beispiel von
klassischer Musik also das gönne ich ihr
auch und dann wird sie merken oh da
fehlt mir aber doch einiges ich bin ganz
sicher sie wird sich nicht in die
wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeit oder die
Dienste von irgendwelchen russischen
gaskonzernen begeben die wird also keine
Pipelines verlegen aber dass sie
international eine Rolle spielen wird
oder sozial caritatives Engagement zeigt
für Projekte die ihr wichtig sind das
glaube ich schon sie ist ein homo
politikus und ohne Politik geht es bei
ihr nicht und bei mir auch nicht
Wolfgang Bosbach vielen herzlichen Dank
für dieses Gespräch danke Ihnen